[Music]
submit
confronted his parents about marrying
jenny
and what happened it was beyond what i
expected
first of all his dad was throwing
major shades
plus we have to talk about brittany
meeting up with
yazan's brother who by the end of their
conversation
felt moved enough to wipe away her tears
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
you know what we are not going to waste
any time
i'll get to brittany learning about
yazan's dad's death threat
in just a moment but first let's get
into this intense confrontation that
was honestly hard to watch it all
started
when cement planned to tell his mom and
dad about
marrying ginny after they got engaged
but his soon-to-be wife god willing
got a little too excited and decided to
tell his brother
their plans which was a huge mistake
because he has a problem with keeping it
a secret
so his wife stepped in and convinced
submit
to tell his parents immediately
i'm keep telling them since a long time
i want to marry i want to marry him i
want to marry like
fine worried i think you should inform
to mom and dad that you're getting
engaged tomorrow that's a big day for
you
and big day for them as well
if they come to know from anybody else
that you're going to hurt them more and
i think the situation will be more sore
she was so right she was and a part of
me
wanted her to be wrong i'm not gonna lie
because while all of this
sounds good it's a recipe for disaster
which is exactly what we got
submit invited his parents over and his
mom
she came in hot with a full on attitude
first day many
once they got in the house and said
their phony hellos to jenny
submit broke the news
i love your son i'm not leaving him
alone jenny
you do not say that to an angry mother
you don't do that
she got a little bold right there
luckily smith's mom didn't understand
that
by the way his mother's reaction to the
news
wasn't too surprising it was smith's dad
who shocked me
he just kept coming with jab after jab
not only throwing shade at jenny but his
own sign
foreign
jenny doesn't know what's going on right
now but
she knows that look it's that angry mean
mad
lady look yes and it's also that
you better leave my child alone look
i've seen it before now before we judge
submits mom and dad
too harshly i think it's fair to really
consider their point of view
his mom thinks that when people see smit
and jenny together
they question whether she and her
husband instilled
the right values in him she also
revealed that they feel ashamed
and walk around with their eyes lowered
because of
this situation now in my opinion
walking around feeling shameful that's a
choice
that's not jenny or submit's fault at
the same time
because this is such an odd relationship
i understand their disappointment but
let's be real here
parents have the hard task of having to
accept their kids choices all the time
you either choose your child's happiness
or the opinions of people out in the
world who quite frankly
don't really care about you
[Music]
i cannot do this to this family i need
to just go back to america
those are moments where i think to
myself
what are the producers thinking
what's the camera crew thinking what
could possibly be going through your
mind
as you're witnessing that it was wild
and heartbreaking all at the same time
and it's somebody's family you know
all right we gotta move on to britney
who said goodbye to our friend
angela this episode she headed back to
the states
so in honor of her honesty with brittany
we're going to take a moment to just
bask in her realness
one more time brittany has really gotten
herself into the middle
of a very serious situation
i love brittany and i want her to have
love and happiness in her life and i
know that yazan brings that to her
i'm just not sure if they should risk so
much for it
oh my goodness to be in your shoes
i know it's like crazy i don't i can't
even believe i'm in my shoes
we all need friends like angela well
when it comes to brittany and yazan
earlier in the episode he brought a
translator
to dinner and because of that britney
was able to clearly understand
that if they move forward with their
relationship
yazan could possibly be disowned by his
family
to learn more about how serious the
situation is
she took the translator to go meet with
yazan's brother
who has never really been that fond of
her there are people in the family who
genuinely hate him now and
it might get to the point where they
might decide to kill him
wow
because they believe that if when he
does that he's not just
affecting himself he's affecting the
entire family
[Music]
now brittany cried for a good little
minute
i think on top of it just being too much
she was also scared for yazan
and his brother felt that as well
what's hard huh it's just like it's so
hard because i don't want him to lose
you
i want to stand next to him
i know that ezra loves me very much
thank you
if you thought that this man was
beautiful before
i know the moment he stood up to wipe
those cheers away
took it to another level because it did
for me
that was so sweet he also put his foot
down
and made it clear to brittany that if
they move forward
yazan is going to lose a lot of things
that are
very important to him so she needs to
step up and be everything he needs
unlike submits brother he's willing to
cover for them
as they try
[Music]
left the conversation with a lot to
think about
but i just want to take a moment to show
some appreciation
to this translator adam he is
the real mvp of this episode
adam came through and brought some
understanding
and i'm sure there were times where he
was like what did i just get hired for
it is not every day that you run into a
brittany and yazan
situation all right well next week on
the other way
the fight between submit and his parents
continues
i may need to go meditate after that all
right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual
we are covering it all i'll see you next
[Music]
time